how great were those performances of the
denominator songs ladies and gentlemen
special thanks to John Legend the
sweater gospel choir from South Africa
and Fatima Robinson who did the staging
and now guest one on please welcome
Academy Award nominee Liam Neeson them
from Slumdog Millionaire Frieda Pinto
bonsoir to the malt which is how we know
we're here to present the award for Best
Foreign Language Film the languages are
German French Japanese and Hebrew but
the teams cut across all spoken words
terror from Germany the story of the
birth of a political terrorist group
assimilation from France a teacher
struggles with a new cultural diversity
of his class death from Japan the
unlikely tale of what happens when an
unemployed classical musician takes a
job in a mortuary crime from Austria a
simple little robbery becomes an epic
tale of revenge war from Israel a
soldier reexamined his participation in
a controversial military action and the
Oscar goes to departures Japan directed
by Ichiro Takeda
thank you to all the Academy thank you
to everybody who helped me this film I
am very very happy thank you I am here
because of films this is a new departure
for me and I will we be back
I hope thank you
cool with the oscars for best actor and
actress we'll find out when the Academy
Awards continue on ABC